I feel a little scared about if I, you know, just walk down the street.
Cops might just think I'm doing something bad.
And then, if I try to explain to them, they won't listen and just start beating me up...
...and doing terrible things to me.
I think there's like, this anxiety that kind of comes with being biracial,...
...like the kind that eats away at you.
Almost like you have to prove yourself like you're one of the other.
For example, I hate the phrase "you're not black" all the time.
People sometimes think like, I'm supposed to talk ghetto or whatever that is.
"Oh, she uneducated because she's African-American."
Because I'm Hispanic or Latino, I can't have a lot of money.
Just this weekend, I went with my friend to Urban Outfitters and we went shopping...
...and I really wanted to try on this dress.
And then, this lady there, she's kinda like watching me...
...and it's like, I'm not gonna steal it or anything.